go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back to Griffin with Griffin
your favorite podcast
today I'm gonna get into like ah Aaron
Rodgers got injured oh man that sucks
sucks sucks for the season the league it
was just crazy fight with some cops and
some that's just white wedding that's
the only way I could describe it it was
a white wedding all right
um other news and notes sag after update
little thoughts but either way
welcome back
[Music]
shut down
what's up y'all welcome back to Roofing
with Griffin
Griffin with Griffin uh it's me Eric
Griffin your star I I'm I it's a comedy
podcast sometimes sometimes I'm serious
sometimes I'm not but I'm always 100 me
authentic off the cuff Wednesday's live
every week thanks for being here
if this is your first time that's what
it's about if you're a long time
listener or you know what it while it's
about thank you for coming back I
appreciate you
all right so what we got here uh make
sure you subscribe you know if you hit
the Subscribe button right now and you
hit the like button you hit the
notifications button you know when I'm
gonna go live on Wednesdays I wish it
was more consistent but you know life
gets in the way you know you know so we
do it live I'm on Twitch all the time
you know so come check me out game you
want to see some old man gaming come
check me out there and you can be a
subscriber there you could be a YouTube
member if you just want to like support
the show and keep the thing going you
can also do that also on patreon I
appreciate you guys for you know all the
ones that have done that I appreciate
that
appreciate you so
um
anyways
welcome back uh to riflewood Griffin we
are here once again
you know how it goes you know what I
mean
we um why doesn't this average there we
go
awesome thanks for everybody that's
listening
um you know the people that listen on
all the ways you can listen to the
podcast I also appreciate that that is
helpful too
you know I like to get to my questions
question and answer stuff I'd like all
the comments and if you uh got something
in chat live right now you know I just
put that
q a up right there so you can always
write something there I may or may not
get to it but it is what it is
so yeah welcome back to riffing with
Griffin
oh man what's going on we got a big uh
actually today we got a big 20-week body
scan you know they they zoom in on the
the baby and it's like you know 3D 4D
whatever they call it machine and that's
when we find out you know it's actually
from being 100 with you it makes me a
little nervous because it's like you
know you had this big 14-week
appointment and they're looking at the
nose and the spine and they're saying
like hey everything looks good
everything's fine and then you're like
you know you look up like well what
happens at the 20-week appointment
that's like a more intense appointment
so you know it's like you think
everything's fine but then they're
telling you that 20-week appointment
actually this is where they really find
stuff and you're just like what it's
like ah you know you just think having a
kid is like the movies you know you just
they get a p stick and then like nine
months later it's like a beautiful
healthy six-month-old baby pops out and
you know
you know I mean it's like uh but you
know fingers crossed everybody knock on
wood
um
so there there's that that's what's
going on there
um yeah man I've just been uh super busy
you know so I I I was I'm one of the
lucky ones that I I'm on a independent
movie production that's about to start
you know they want we got the the waiver
to work so you know as you guys know all
that stuff that is going on with yeah I
got some eye boogers going on all that
stuff that's going on with you know the
SAG strike and I don't know if there's
any end in sight
so I got that going on lucky me right
um
yeah man it's uh you know and then like
I tweeted something about the SAG strike
a few days ago because I was just
thinking about this
as I was talking about it even on the on
the podcast last week I was thinking
that like you know there's a hundred and
sixty thousand sag members right I would
venture to say that every sag member
probably play pays around 50 to 75
dollars a month
on streaming services Netflix Hulu
Paramount Plus Peacock
um Disney you know the Disney Hulu ESPN
bundle
um whatever streaming services that you
might have Apple TV all the streaming
services that we that we pay for I bet
you
the whole entire Union is paying 50 to
75 a month which is equivalent to around
7 to 10 million dollars a month
it's just I don't know what we're doing
like the only thing that's going to make
these people come to the table is a loss
of Revenue no one is not subscribing to
their Netflix anymore for actors no
one's doing it it's not like 50 million
people are like oh wow you're this is
what you're doing to our favorite actors
and shows we're gonna cancel our
subscriptions if that happens they will
come to the table a deal will be made
but if the unions themselves we're not
even willing to do that to to stop our
subscriptions to make them lose you know
and then let's count the writers Union
in too I mean between the writers Union
the actors Union maybe even the like the
other unions for like the the makeup
artists and all those people what if
that is equivalent to like 20 million
dollars a month a month
if we all shut that down or maybe we all
put that money into a pot to help people
pay their bills that are in that are in
need so we could keep the strike going I
don't know what the answer is I wasn't
voted president
right I don't know but it just seems
like
that's a better
you want to strike them it's better to
like not we're still giving them money
is it's just weird
it's a weird thing you know what I mean
it's freaking weird all right um
let's go to the comments this week's
comments you know what first I'll go to
the Q a see if I have any see if I have
any questions uh somebody said Matthew
McAllister favorite NFL team yeah
I don't know if I have one right now
I just because you know you're in La I
like the Rams because I'm from La so if
I had to say my favorite would be the
Rams just because I'm from LA
um
well I'm gonna get into this later how
bad do the Jets feel about Aaron Rodgers
that's what I'm talking about today
um okay I'm not getting into like
whatever your weird politics not
answering that question
uh when is the last time you played Halo
Infinity that game is garbage no one
plays it go to this site called Uh Uh
current like it's called player count go
to player count on online just just
Google player count and it'll show you
the the amount of people playing a game
currently online at you know they have
their connected to the servers no one's
playing Halo
not enough people this would a complete
and utter disaster
all right let's go to the comments
let's go to the comment section baby
of course there's always like there's
always like a funny troll comment you
know and this one's a good one uh Asha
Asha L mighty09 that's why I have my
Captain America shirt on last week and
this guy goes Captain America is looking
a little rough
okay that's a you know what I mean
hey
uh there wasn't really a lot of good
comments this week
somebody was trying to Mr Potato Head
one six one
I don't know if that's a troll I don't
know what that is but whatever workers
don't deserve to get profit sharing for
being in a production since they're not
in on the hook to pay the bill if the
production is a loss your risks are
reward yeah I mean I don't know what
that person means by that but I mean if
it's referring to the strike and like
you know I just think that one of the
issues is like if like let's just talk
about Netflix in their original
programming so like if you're Netflix
and you're you're saying okay we we want
some original programming for our
platform so we're going to go to our
production company we're going to be
like all right uh we're gonna pay you to
make this all right so here's money to
make this production here's money to pay
your actors and people and we're going
to call it a buyout we're buying you out
because this is our product that we're
gonna put on our platform we're paying
for it we're paying you to make it we're
paying you to be in it and okay it's
ours thank you for all the work you did
here's some money for that and now it's
ours
our mindset is still in the old way
because of network and AD Revenue so the
old way was if the show was being played
you should get paid right and that's
based off because there was ad Revenue
Netflix is like well we paid for it this
is ours we we made it we we made you
know what I mean it's like if I if I
commission a painting this would be like
this Netflix is like hey I want you to
paint something for me here's millions
of dollars paint this painting and then
they take their painting and they put it
up in their Museum right and they're
like okay thank you you've been paid now
we put the painting in their Museum and
then the painter walks into the museum
and he's like wait a minute you're
charging people to look at this painting
and then Netflix is like yeah we paid
you for it we already paid you to make
it thank you okay you want do you want
to look at it because there's a ticket
booth that you can pay for to come
inside this Museum
this idea that
you made the painting
you you got paid to make the painting
and now the painting sitting in a museum
and you walk into the museum and you're
like well how come everybody is
paying to see this I should get a little
bit of that money
no
I mean I'm just saying that's their
perspective
I mean that's how it goes for anything
if you own a business and let's say you
like pay a graphic designer and you go
hey um
can you make a logo for me you paid a
person for the logo now the logo you use
it and then people are paying like say
your for your only fans or patreon or
something like that and then that logo
person comes and goes hold on a second
you're making money off my logo I should
get paid it's like no I paid you for
that you know you know what I mean
that's the other perspective I mean I
just I don't know sometimes I don't
sometimes it's like I don't get it I
just again like I said last week
the business has changed and we haven't
changed with it so I don't know
uh Dylan
Murrell gray said right now no one is
asking people to boycott the streaming
service to start a campaign I mean yeah
that's exactly
it's but it's like I don't know man
because it's like we just want them to
like come to the table and with a fair
deal we don't want people to stop
watching because we gonna need those
people once the deal is cut
it's very nuanced you know
uh very nuanced uh David David
[Music]
whatever just [__] stupid names guys
just have your goddamn name okay all
right I watched The Flash for a second
time the other day mainly because Flash
is my favorite superhero since I was a
kid it's bad but I enjoyed it second
time probably won't ever watch it again
though love the podcast Eric great as
always you know what
I actually watched it on a plane the
other day it's still terrible
but but but like if I would have just
watched it on the plane not pay for it
in the theater I probably would have
been like okay you know like if it was
like if it was like how they do like
Marvel shows on Disney if DC had their
own version of that and that movie was
on it I'd be like all right that was
okay you know but like to like get in my
car go to a movie theater pay that
amount of money and sit in there with
the expectations of that
disappointing but I get what you're
saying right you know so thanks for
being here
um all right that's enough comments for
today you know oh Janine's back oh I
just saw this
oh she was like hurting about Aaron
Rodgers yeah I'm about to get into that
let me go to my let me just check the
questions one more time because I think
I got some more of them
um let's see here what we got here no
there's no more of those okay we're done
with that all right so thank you very
much for the super chats and all that I
mean you guys can help support the show
when you guys do that so I I do
appreciate that so all right let's see
what's going on today yeah so we should
probably just get right into it huh
let's just get right into it man
Aaron Rodgers you know damn so I will
say this starting for the new NFL season
I want I don't want to say it was
disappointing right let's like maybe
that's too strong
maybe that's too strong of word
um
but I
I kind of felt a little let down
you know you know what I mean I kind of
felt a little let down
uh for the the opening of the season I
think a lot of teams didn't live up to
the hype that they that they
you know started with right
so
I don't unders you know you go to this
they have this thing this pre this this
you go to this NFL site and it's just
like okay here we go finally Jesus
Christ man okay here we go
so some of these scores like like you
know you had a lot of hype for this
season I mean especially in the AFC the
afcs seem to have a ton of teams that
have potential to win the Super Bowl
tons of teens mans the chief Chiefs the
Bengals the Browns
um the Ravens right the Jaguars uh then
you had these like Fringe teams like the
Steelers where the Broncos gonna be back
in the mix you had to you know you got
the Chargers the Dolphins that's nine
teams only six or seven make the
playoffs you know and the Jets you know
that you're talking like in the AFC
I think this is the first time legit you
had
over like you usually in the NFL like
you go oh that's the best team that they
they are the Super Bowl favorites you
have so many teams preseason that looked
like they all had a chance to win the
Super Bowl like they legit shot and the
NFL's like that anyway there's always a
team that just comes out of nowhere
right but the Jets were one of these
teams that you thought oh man this is
this is this is it is this it for the
Jets do they finally have like not just
they have a great team and there's hope
but there's expectations for them to go
far in the playoffs for like you know
just like Tom Brady did with Tampa just
like uh Matthew Stafford did with the
Rams you thought is Aaron Rodgers going
to bring his four-time MVP Super Bowl
winning self to the Jets change that
culture and go and it looked like it was
going to happen with the Hard Knocks and
then like oh man he Rogers comes out on
the field the place is going bananas
he's got this like youthful look on his
face you know he's been a diva for the
last five six years in Green Bay right
he doesn't show up to mini camp he's
always you know doing this weird stuff
in the press and then you know he's like
dude all these weird demands and and and
now he's with the Jets he shows up to
mini camp he's chilling with the young
players he's got this like look on his
face like you know he wants to get back
at the world like oh I'm gonna show you
Green Bay I'ma show the world I still
got it I'm gonna show everybody I'm one
of the best quarterbacks ever four plays
into the season
ending injury Achilles tear and it was
such a fluke like what a fluke fluke
injury like it you know it didn't even
look like
it didn't even look like I was just
talking I see somebody in the chat I did
I was only talking about the AFC the NFC
has teams too I'm just saying in the AFC
there were like 10 teams in the AFC to
have a chance to win the Super Bowl
that's what I'm saying nfcs a whole
other story
um but anyways so four plays into Aaron
Rodgers season at 39 years old he tears
his Achilles and it didn't even it just
looked like a routine sack right it just
looked routine but just what happens
when somebody's 39 years old trying to
play football like what Tom Brady did
was just if you think about it now
amazing that he didn't get hurt but you
know you have to like take care of your
body in a way that is like even more
than like Europe like Aaron Rodgers was
in the bed one he was in great shape you
know he he you saw in the Hard Knocks
you know people that around him they're
all talking about what great how great
he looked and you know what he was doing
for his body and all that but it's like
damn
a routine stack and you're out for I
mean out for the season and you know
what in my opinion that's it this is it
for Aaron Rodgers that's it he's 39.
Achilles Terror rehab is like 18 months
that's going into the next season
and then is he going to be 100 is he you
know he he would have not played
football for all that time what is he
gonna be 40 going off 41
this might be the end of a very
very illustrious career but also
disappointing career right to be someone
with that kind of talent
I mean Aaron Rodgers is one of the best
quarterbacks ever just eye test like if
you know I don't I'm not a big like X's
and O's football guy but I know when I
see this guy play football and the way
he throws the ball and just you're just
like damn this guy is like just accurate
you know
and it sucks that his career went out
like this and he's such a polarizing
figure too right so polarizing he very
much reminds me of Kobe Bryant because I
think Kobe had the same thing he was
just like this polarizing guy that you
loved him and hated him and then like he
ended his career with it like two
Achilles tears or something like I think
I think Kobe had two very terrible
injuries later in life and he was just
at that point 35 36 he tried to come
back no one comes back from those
injuries 100 and when you're already old
in terms of professional athlete age you
know like dog years there's no coming
back from that you know and I just I
just think it's terrible we got robbed
of seeing this
we'll never know now
we'll never know and the team still won
you know that team is oh man when Aaron
Rodgers that team is fantastic that
defense Garrett Wilson on the uh as a
number one receiver the dude's a beast
two great running backs a stellar
defense top-notch Corners like this team
was on its way there's I just don't know
it was funny to me like Zach Wilson you
know like if you're let's say you're
Zach Wilson you're a professional
athlete you were the number two or three
pick in the draft your your career is
bombing your agent is probably like not
taking your calls the way they used to
right and you're sitting on the sideline
now this your Idol
it's Aaron Rodgers you can learn from
this guy and he has he was talking about
it all off season like wow so he got to
watch Aaron Rodgers and like Aaron
Rodgers in his ear like oh man because
Aaron knows he's only gonna play a
couple years and he's like look kid I'm
gonna show you how to do this right and
you can see it in preseason he was like
Aaron's telling them something he goes
in the game dude throws a 50-yard bomb
you know what I mean it's like so then
Aaron Rodgers goes out and you're over
there on the sideline
what's going on in his head I mean he
had to be like
yes you know what I mean I mean secretly
how do you not and now he's in there
playing and then they're talking to him
about it after listen
this this could change Zach Wilson's
life he was about to be done in terms of
like being a starting quarterback or how
about this in line to get a lot of money
now
now he can play himself into 35 million
dollars like they're he's never going to
get one of those top-notch unless they
win the Super Bowl let's say he has one
of those he game managing seasons and he
like gets them far and they get to the
he he might play himself into
generational wealth because of this
injury so but it is terrible it really
is and I really did think and I thought
like I was saying earlier that I think
that the first week of the NFL it was a
little disappointing
um you know so the Ravens won against
the Texans but they should the Texans
you know they got a rookie quarterback
going but but I don't know if the Ravens
I don't know how they looked right
then you had the buck then you talk
about the NFC the NFC is so wide open
it's so trash
you know as a as a whole but you know
Dallas 49ers man
those two teams man look fantastic you
know they really look good
Eagles
listen
I think the Eagles are going to be great
it's just hard like talk whatever smack
you want to talk about Bill Belichick
that guy
that's a great coach and he he had his
team prepared and they almost won that
game so I think it's more of a like the
Patriots were just doing that Patriot
thing they had a lot of time to prepare
for the Eagles but they just aren't
talented enough but they almost won that
game so but I still think the Eagles are
a top team so you got the Eagles Dallas
49ers that's the cream of the crop of
the NFC and then you just had a bunch of
like other stuff you know jaguars look
good right
um Steelers I thought they were gonna be
better they looked terrible okay
um the Raiders and Broncos I mean can
you imagine the Raiders are number one
in the AFC West that's another thing
that was disappointed Kansas City lost
Chargers lost great game though best
game of the weekend was the Dolphins and
Chargers my goodness Tua Tua looks like
he looks like an MVP so you know it just
was it was a little let down I thought
it was a disappointing uh first week and
then Aaron Rodgers going down really
really just made that first week like
you know it's like damn dude that sucks
right that sucks but you know here we
are
we're back at it so we'll see what
happens next week so you know if a
football fan or not you will be hearing
about football a lot from
um from me
um on this
yeah see yeah somebody Isaac in the chat
Seahawks look bad too yes Seahawks did
not look good I just think it's like you
know first week Jitters I guess a lot of
expectations on people on teams so we'll
see where they go from here all right
guys for the rest of the episode I got a
lot of uh internet stories I wanted to
get into
um
you know I got a lot of like
this is something it was just it was
just like one of those weeks where there
was just a lot of like you know
stories that just caught my eye when I
was like hey you know I want to talk
about this
first up McDonald's McDonald's plans to
remove self-service soda machines over
theft and hygiene concerns
I mean
what first of all
when you're going to
uh fast food restaurant or any
restaurant and they got a self-service
soda machine
this is how I do it
I go hey
can I have a cup for some water and I
put up my air quotes
if they give me the cup they know I'm
getting soda like stop what are we
talking about you know you know oh yeah
the waters and the waters in the same
place as the soda yeah I'm gonna get a
Sprite sorry
so is this the theft they're talking
about I think theft is a strong word for
getting some soda in a cup while you why
you just paid you know whatever you paid
for for your for your meal you know you
got a Big Mac and a large fries I mean
you're like I just have some water and
you get a little sprite I mean is that
theft
I guess I mean technically but but then
the hygiene concerns you know that's
something that you don't even like to
think about you don't even want to think
that like you know somebody's going up
to the soda machine and they're like
touching it with their hands the spout
or you know like you know how little
kids are they walking up and they just
putting their lips on it and you know
you know I don't know it's like I saw I
remember seeing this really crazy story
in a Whole Foods there's a guy in the
Whole Foods where the food is and he's
drinking soup out of the ladle you know
he's putting it in
and then putting it back in
I mean you know there are people like
that out there I just feel like we don't
like to think about it but why would
this fast food place care about hygiene
if I'm just saying if we really think
about like are they I are they going
over there wiping the place down
regularly
you know you know you go to a movie
especially you go to a movie theater you
go to a movie theater and then like you
go get your soda butt thing you go over
to the soda area it's a mess
who knows what's going on here people
aren't washing their hands who knows
what people are doing it's like you know
when you go get a lid for your for your
cup everybody's hands are touching the
lids everybody's grabbing so it's like
hygiene concerns are always a thing
you know it's always a thing
so I just thought I was like okay so
McDonald's and then the reason also is
like there's so much like delivery now I
don't know how many people are actually
going into the restaurants and eating
food I mean we're not gonna call
McDonald's a restaurant but you know you
know what I mean so I just thought that
that was like a weird thing that they
were uh that they were like um
that I wonder how many other places are
going to do this they're just going to
get rid of the and we'll get the soda
for you I mean it's kind of like you
know it's like I mean
it was lazy it's kind of lazy it's like
this kind of like self-service when you
go to the supermarket they're just
trying to remove jobs from people and
this is one of those things that was
like all right well now we don't have to
do the sodas here's a cup go ahead get
your soda I mean they had to know people
were gonna like it's weird because like
when you go to certain places it's like
free refills so if you have a place that
has free refills
then if somebody that like got a water
cup is just getting some soda how's I
mean is it all that serious but
who knows all right next up this one I
thought was like this is a sign of the
times man a Virginia House candidate
called out for resurfaced porn videos
all right
the internet
pre-internet people could have a past
pre-internet if you did some stuff in
your youth that you say were not proud
of or you know you just made young
people mistakes or you just had young
people experiences before the internet
it was it was the past the past was the
past and who am I what am I now the
internet
now you know what I mean so we didn't
know anything about people so it was
like whatever okay if something's
surface we'd be like whoa but like it's
none of our business
the internet has made everything our
business and you are whoever you were
for the rest of your life that's just
how people think now
so if you did something in your past
and it's on the internet that's who you
are forever there's no growth no one
could grow on the internet no one can be
a new person a better person or learn
from anything because if you said
something in the past if you did
something in the past that's who you are
for the rest of your life on the
internet
I mean the internet basically I mean but
people change people change where
a hoe can literally become a housewife
you know what I mean the internet's the
only place that can happen because you
look at somebody's Instagram from like
their 19 20 21 22 they're on the
internet wilding out you know just
thirst traps and all kinds of stuff you
know and then they turn 28 29 30 and
they met someone and now they had a baby
they're a family person and now their
pictures are different they're looking
at you know they're you know what I mean
it's like they've grown so that's what I
feel about this
this lady had some fun in her youth
maybe she was you know she was like she
needed the money or maybe she was just
like oh this is gonna be fun
and now it comes out
I think it's unfair I think it's an
unfair characterization
to like look at somebody you know
let people show you who they are now
you know
I mean it's not an absolute thing you
know it's like
I hope she just addresses it and just be
like look I was young I did this it's
fine here's who I am now you know if you
have a problem with that well I'm sorry
but this is what I'm trying to do now
it's just it sucks man it's like
everything we do on the internet stays
on there forever and it's a shame it's
just this new world that we live in as
opposed to like you know I'm old enough
to remember when we we didn't know
nothing about people you know what I
mean
so
I just I feel I I feel for this lady I
don't know the whole story this is just
my general thoughts about this subject
not necessarily this person but I'm just
I just think that I'd give people some
Grace find out you know I think we need
to do some more research but you know
this is the kind of thing the internet
just attacks man you know you find out
somebody did porn and the next thing you
know you're like whoa they're the devil
you know what I mean you know what I'm
saying it's like crazy man
it's crazy but you know like I say I
feel for this lady and I hope that she
um
I hope it works out you know
all right in AI news you know I love
talking about AI so Tim Burton's seeing
his animation style imitated by AI is
like a robot taking your Humanity I
think that's an extreme
view of it but I get it
but there's the other another view of
this could be like when you have such a
distinct Style
that you you know you have a stop it's
like when a comedian
is doing like someone's voice
and impersonation you know when someone
does an impersonation of someone because
of like they have these mannerisms and
all this
and then you see that we always
appreciate it you know when a human
being does an impersonation of like
whoever we're always like oh wow that's
amazing
so I think this is equivalent to that I
think that the AI is just you know it
looks oh here's the style that this guy
has and I'm just gonna they're gonna
make it like that
I don't know
I think they were afraid we really are
afraid of AI you know we don't know what
to think of it
it's crazy how it has such an evil
connotation now when you look back at
you know when you when like movies like
Jurassic Park came out and you know all
the all the Terminator and all the
things we used
when it was just called computer
generated you know CGI computer
generated images or whatever the
whatever that stands for everything was
like whoa the CGI is great in this I
mean every movie superhero movie and
everything that's CGI
uh Lord of the Rings had these huge
battle scenes
the it's CGI
you know and we were fine with it we
were like okay well this is how you make
a big scene like that so we can get
enjoyment
now switch it now it's like bit it's
evolved to
AI it's helping generate these things
now all of a sudden we're like oh my God
this is evil this was the natural
progression
you know and we like it we want to see
dinosaurs that look like real dinosaurs
we don't want to see animatronics we
don't we don't like none of that we like
the idea that our imagination can be put
on screen that's why we like the movies
that we like
action movies Sci-Fi movies we want to
see an alien really look like an alien
and we'll be like wow we really can't
suspend our disbelief this is like this
is like another Universe we're in right
now and now we're saying well hold on a
second
we don't want that Universe taking over
our universe so it's like we're at a
weird Crossroads with AI especially in
entertainment
and then you and we have a sort of this
kind of feeling about it where you have
someone like Tim Burton who's like a
robot is taking your Humanity you're
like oh man I know I know how he feels I
know what he means but we have to find a
way to like integrate this in a safe way
I mean who knows where it's gonna go
from here man it's so crazy
you know it is so crazy so we will see
where it goes from here right guys
strange strange strange strange but I
thought that was like a really good uh I
thought that was like this is like Tim
Burton is like voicing how a lot of
people feel about
AI
even though it's a tool that I think 10
years ago if that tool was available in
a way that we they would use it and be
like wow look how great this is so I
don't know it's a it's a weird thing I
don't know where we're going with it man
but we'll see
okay so I saw this story a husband
abandons wife during connecting flight
for being late and the internet is
taking his side
you know this is about like how are you
in your relationship
let's say I'm going to a show let's say
Rachel's traveling with me and
we are going to a show I mean she's
coming with me and I gotta get to my
show
you know let's say it's a theater gig
it's one night there's a connecting
flight I got it the flight already lands
from the East doesn't come from the west
coast to the east coast you know it's
like it was a 9 A.M flight but by the
time I get there it's going to be four
the shows at eight I gotta get this
flight
she's Dilly dallying at the store she
might be like well I'm going to the I go
babe we got to catch this flight all
right we can't miss this flight and she
off
you know
doing stuff in the airport
I might leave her
you know what I mean get on the flight
you get on the flight you're like okay I
hope she comes you're waiting waiting
waiting and then you know at the gate
you know maybe they even called all
right Chuck Griffin you need to come to
the gate 75 Rachel Carson last call
you're like I gotta get on
it's just but you know
you're gonna get in trouble but are you
is it Justified
but it's like it's different
but here's the thing though this is why
it's nuanced it's Case by case let's say
every time I go someplace with Rachel
she always almost missing the flight
every time I go with her she got to go
shopping at the airport every time you
know what I mean if it's one of those
cases then it's like you're like all
right listen I'm getting on this plane
all right so don't whatever you doing
over there hurry up cause I'm getting on
this plane but if that never happens if
that's not a normal thing and this is a
responsible person that you trust your
spouse or whoever it is and then they're
not showing up
I'm not getting on a plane because I'm
gonna be like
where's my wife
you know you're gonna be like
something's up and you're gonna go find
out
so you need more information in this
situation but if you're texting your
wife and you're like hey babe the
flight's boarding and she's like I know
just give me a second I'm I'm at the
I'm at the duty free okay and I'm trying
to decide what makeup I want to buy from
this or oh there's some like alcohol or
there's some whatever she's like you
know you know what they have at the
duty-free I don't know she's like
browsing at the airport shops that's
different yeah you lead that chick bye
catch the next flight because I got to
go to my show or wherever you're going
you know I mean it's like I'm not saying
I would do that now because first we
wouldn't be traveling I'm not talking
about pregnant Rachel I'm just saying
it's like it really depends on you know
I hate when like these kind of stories
come up because it nothing's absolute
this is a case by case what is going on
in your situation right so it's like I
don't know I just like would you leave
your would you leave your wife what
would you guys do you guys tell me in
the chat tell me in the comments section
tell me about your personal relationship
uh you know if if you're getting on a
flight and your wife girlfriend she's
nowhere to be found in your relationship
are you leaving her let me know
oops let's see
all right next story from one of my
favorite sites puberty you gotta follow
them
guys Australia wants to enforce a curfew
on cats
cats killed two billion animals in
Australia every year
you know what I'm starting to think
about cats
maybe cats aren't pets
like how many times we gonna hear
stories about cats
eating their owners
how many videos we gonna watch of cats
like attacking dogs when I was a kid you
used to think the dog was like they
always had like the dog chasing the cat
in the movies in the cartoons so you
always thought like dogs were like nah
man dogs get punked by cats all the time
just search the internet it's crazy
I don't think cats are pets
here's the thing I think cats are just
the little people of the cat world so
you have like a tiger is a tiger a pet
no this is a fierce ass Beast
cats might just be like the dwarf
version and we're treating them like oh
because they're little we're like oh
they can't die but you need to know like
in the human world dude
I have friends who are like little
little dudes like that they're cool
people they they bosses they they do
just what anybody else does you know
what I mean it's like we don't treat
them different
like they're not us yeah
I think we've been treating cats the
wrong way I think that cats these cats
we have in the house they're just like
oh man if I was 60 pounds heavier I'd be
running stuff maybe I I don't I don't
think
when you have like a little like let's
say this let me give you an example of
something so you have like a house cat
that looks like a Jaguar like if it was
if you if you added a hundred pounds to
this animal it would be it would be a
wild beast and you couldn't have it in
your house you shouldn't get some wild
ass animal right
and cats seem to act the same way
they're just little
dogs
whatever the biggest dog is a Mastiff or
something dog even a little Chihuahua
they pretty much
ultimately have the same personality in
a sense that they're a loyal dog
they know their place just a dog
even a wolf if you domesticate a wolf
dang acting Wolfie you know they just
it's like but then you have like a wolf
let's say like they're still the same
size as dogs like they they're you know
it's just the wolf is out in the in the
wilderness but you've seen people who
have wolves or you have like a half wolf
half something and and no matter what
size the dog is they pretty much are a
dog
if there was like
we have a dog and then there was like a
hippopotamus sized dog
would it be would it completely act
differently than than the this size dog
I don't know well I'm just saying I
don't think cats are pets
I don't think cats are pets man I think
we've been messing around because that's
why in Australia these cats are out here
murdering stuff
Maybe
maybe we need to like let cats free
I don't know because how many times are
we gonna hear a story about a cat doing
this
you know I know there's a lot of cat
people out there like cats really
depends maybe they don't they don't want
to be they don't want to be there man
that's just I think we're starting to
find out that cats are freaking
dangerous
all right next story so you know this
story is going on right now as you guys
know Danny Masterson from That 70s Show
he had a raid trial he was accused of
raping three women there was a mistrial
and then they had a new trial and they
found him guilty and he's going to jail
for 30 years
he's going away for 30 years he was
found guilty of
his crimes okay that's due process
worked itself out
he had his trial he was found guilty
okay now Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
are friends of this guy
uh and they wrote a letter to the judge
being like hey can you show some
leniency to our friend you know I
all right and so now the internet is
going crazy The Virtue signaling is out
of control you know everybody wants to
show how much they are anti-crime and
they're on their channels like these
people are terrible now listen man
I personally feel like this is a very
nuanced thing I think that
you know if you're like people act like
they would turn their back on all of
their friends they would turn their back
on their family members that they would
turn their back on anyone who was in
that situation so you're saying to me
your brother is accused of this and
found guilty and then you would just
disown them you might
listen
but what I'm saying is I don't think
there's anything this isn't the worst
thing in the world
for to support your friend
I think that they're saying they're I
don't believe that they condone his
behavior at all I think they're just
saying hey judge 30 maybe 25 years uh is
that he's guilty his life is over
he is guilty of his crimes he will
always be now that a criminal
and his friends just want to be like hey
can you show some leniency towards him
and because they did that they're now
being vilified as if
they agree with his crimes and
everything because that's what the
internet likes to do people like to
you know go on there I'm a good person
Patrol and show their fi there's you
know a thousand followers or whatever
like look at me everybody I'm against
this and they're terrible they're
terrible who's that for who's it for
who's it for why
like there's nothing in you to to have
some Grace for someone some compassion
for any situation
I and I'm talking about people that are
not in the situation if you're a victim
of Danny Masterson
hell yeah you might want this guy to die
it is hard for us to go to any victim
and be like hey can you show some mercy
for your victimizer
I am totally understand if that person
is like hell no I hope they die a slow
death I get that
and I also get even because it happens
victims come forward later and be like
you know
I forgive this person and there's people
that do that too you know and then when
it gets to the justice system the
justice system works it out and they go
all right well we're giving this person
this amount sometimes it's not enough
sometimes a crime is committed and then
they don't get enough time or sometimes
our crime is committed and they get like
a bunch of time and if you're a friend
family member of that person I'm talking
about a long time friend like 25 years
you've known a person or whatever and if
you want to like be a character witness
just to be like listen I know my friend
did something wrong and they are guilty
and you're like what can they get you
know 25 years instead of 30 20 years
instead of 30 you know I don't know
whatever the ask was or whatever you're
trying to like help your friend out
I mean I don't think you're a terrible
person because you do that I don't think
you condone bad behavior because you do
that I just think you're being a good
friend you know and uh you know someone
else might be like I think being a good
friend is like just totally disowning
them you know
you know so it's like I don't know it's
like it's a tough thing you know what I
mean it's I just I I just feel like
they're being unfairly characterized
it's what I'm saying you know and it's
just like you know they were just trying
to
um you know they're trying to write a
letter for their friend you know and
that's all I don't think they condone
this but I'm sure they were mortified by
the the what the guy was accused of and
and the fact that he was found guilty
it's got to be like damn you know when
your friend is found guilty when there's
actual evidence when there's a trial two
trials and your friend is going away for
30 years man
what do you do you know what do you do
I'm just saying this I don't think that
I would what I'm saying is I don't think
that I would just abandon you know
depending on what it is you know what I
mean you know it's like let's say Danny
Masterson murdered three people then
what do you do you're gonna be like oh
man I can't talk to this person ever
again you know say what is your line so
you might feel that way too you might be
like well my friend did this to these
people so I'm done with you get out of
here you know it's just like it's so
like
I don't think it's I don't think it's
like we're not in it so that's the thing
too is when I'm saying this the internet
gets involved and then they're like we
got to stay away you know the internet
gets involved and they don't know a lot
of facts or anything they have no
compassion for anyone in this situation
it's just about getting their point
across I guess that's really what I'm
talking about is how how we address
these things and I just think it's
unfair you know I think it's unfair to
the victims I think it's unfair to these
people and then you know so whatever
all right
um
you know
it's um
yeah I see people in the chat going in
about this you know they they like
somebody said they described him as an
outstanding older brother figure and
dedicated loyal husband and an excellent
role model
you know and then yeah it's like you
know
it's like that's what they knew of him
you know so they're just it's like you
know what I think is unfair that that
was
public that they put that out into the
public
you know what I mean it's like all I'm
saying is like you're supporting your
friend and then like they're using that
against you to characterize you in a
certain way I mean it's like does
everything have to go on the internet
you know what I mean it's like damn
that's the sucky part about it but just
I get it
you know like I'm not I get it
I get like if you're someone who is like
this is terrible because you don't want
like not everybody wants to look at
things say like a judge has to look at
things you know like oh like a lawyer
has to look at things you have to spread
everything out and you have to find the
Nuance of everything that you're looking
at most people are just like black and
white most people are just like that
guy's evil and no one should talk to him
ever again I I understand that that
feeling and then I can also understand
the other it's just the way my brain
works when you're a comic and you have
to like look at the nuance and minutia
of everything you could see like okay I
could see them not being evil people
because they they're just trying to
support their friend and I can see the
other side too of people who are victims
close to victims or even these victims
in particular being like no I want that
guy to burn in hell
you know I just feel like
the internet should stay out of it
all right lighter note
so
um
yeah that's my word I say Nuance all the
time because there's no Nuance on the
internet
okay so you people in the chat are like
why is he say Nuance all the time
because a lot of times y'all lack the
ability to see the Nuance not everything
is black and white most of life is in
the gray area learn that [__]
okay Rotten Tomatoes
so this is something I feel like we all
knew about and we just didn't say
anything about it a PR Company
reportedly paid movie critics directly
to manipulate multiple films Rotten
Tomato scores
this is why I say critics are useless I
mean what do we need critics for at this
point
you know what do we need this for
because now we've already felt this way
anyway you know when you go to a Rotten
Tomato score and it's some movie that
you go on I don't what is this movie and
then maybe even watching you're like
well man that was an artsy mess it's not
fun at all and then the critics give it
like a high score and then you look at
the people who watch it actual people
hundreds of thousands of people who
maybe go to this site and go click click
click click click and you're like there
you go well there shouldn't be that big
of a discrepancy
you know what I mean I just think that
there shouldn't be such a big
discrepancy between what critics think
and what the people that went to go see
it think the only one I care about is
what do the people think when they went
to see it did a large number of people
go see this movie and most of them liked
it then I'm gonna be like oh well maybe
I'm gonna go check that out all right if
like a large number of critics go like a
movie and it's and then a large number
of people that watched it don't like it
it's like whoa what are these critics
looking at I don't know and now we come
to find out that they're being paid
that's like ah man is there no integrity
at all
no integrity at all man so that's crazy
all right
um where we at y'all let's see all right
so oh man we gotta go man I'm almost out
of time all right I wanted I did want to
go into this like I saw this did you
guys see this cop fight on on on Twitter
you know did you see this so
okay so apparently there's a wedding
right
you know there's this wedding and
wait let me see how do I press play on
this
I hope it's not messing up
maybe I won't play the sound because I
don't know if the sound is messing up
sometimes the sound messes up so anyway
the the cops get called to just fight
right you know and now
the these guys
these guys are fighting the cops okay
and see the girl in the red she kicks
the cop in the balls she's tried to kick
the cop in the balls three times that
girl right there gets knocked out she
gets knocked out okay now when you see
this video first of all no respect for
law enforcement at all in this video
none
there's like no reason so the cops come
to break up so a guy was trying to get
into this uh place and then the security
had tried to stop him they had to call
the police everybody's drunk acting
crazy and now the cops all right so you
see that video and you know the internet
is going crazy well they got more
details and they got more angles of the
thing turns out this girl in red she is
continuously trying to hit the cops in
the balls she won't stop
she won't stop she's touching the cops
the cops like hey man get off me and
this guy said hey man you moved back she
after the third kick in the balls he's
like [__]
okay
all right now
then this other girl gets knocked out so
you know at first the Internet is just
gonna go crazy right
the cops hit a woman oh my God the cops
hit a woman the woman got hit
then they show this other video
check this out now so this is the trick
that got knocked the hell out okay so
here's another angle
the woman in black is going for the cops
gun
she is literally reaching for the cops
okay look at her and the cops like no
you
you can't have this gun okay
okay look at look at this look at this
again
so now this guy's going crazy you
knocked my girl out
the
he is just like I can't believe this and
here it is again she goes for the cops
gun
what is my feeling on this
you know
I believe in this situation and and as
being a person of color I'm not I'm not
going to sit here and lie like I've had
like terrible interactions with the
police because I haven't when I was a
kid I did have one incident when I was a
kid where I I felt that the cop was
being racist it was just a situation I'm
at a I'm at a I'm at a dance you know
it's like I went to a boys school we're
at the girls we go to the girls school
dance everybody's standing outside and
this cop walked through the whole crowd
came over to me and my friends who were
the only guys around that were like not
white and they were like what are you
doing here and I was like what we're
here for the dance
you know what I mean it was like I was
like whoa so but other than that and
that was freaking 40 years ago or
however you know 35 years ago whatever
it is right times have changed so I'm
not gonna but
to me these cops showed unbelievable
restraint
like this could have gone and we've seen
it on the news this situation could have
gone listen if this was a black party
and the cops came and and a black woman
was reaching for the cops gun first of
all I don't even think it would have
gotten that far
the cops are trying to get there they're
going okay stop stop everybody back up
everybody back up and then this drunk
girl is trying to kick him in the balls
three times
the fact that it got to three times is
like what are we doing I mean like when
you see this what I love about this
video and the footage that they have is
everybody has to shut up
all the people who are like oh the cop
hit a woman and then then it comes out
she tried to grab his gun
so if she would have got the gun out
what was she gonna do is she gonna shoot
people
then what right
so it's like it's so new nuanced
because it's like the cops did a
terrible job getting this situation in
order the people there have zero respect
for law enforcement zero respect and how
do you fix this situation at that point
hands needed to be thrown you know
hands needed to be thrown and when you
now see this footage like I don't want
to like it's like I don't want to hear
you you know like it's like you know
it's like you know like I say the
internet gets a hold of things and
you know they got a virtue signal on
their channel so they got to be like
dude oh look at this this is Powerball I
can't believe that this happened then
they're like oops she wasn't going for
the cops gun
this is one of those you know like
you're a misogynistic Pig if you go
somebody says you never hit a woman
right that's what they say you never hit
a woman
never like Bill Burr's joke never
never
[Laughter]
this is like one of those weird ass
um
you know what I mean
this is just one of those weird ass uh
freaking
[Laughter]
this is like this is when film
everything situation
I'm glad they got the video footage of
this because this is like so crazy
you know what what like what a complete
crazy utter situation man I've gone over
an hour wow that's crazy uh what time is
it 11 45 I gotta go guys I got like a I
got I got business I need to take care
of I had some other things I wanted to
talk about too but we'll get into that
next time guys I want to thank you for
watching riffing with Griffin you know
you know it's all nuanced today's word
of the day
nuanced right so
again you know make sure you check out
subscribe to the channel
um that helps you know if you want to be
a YouTube member if you want to you know
if you want to support the channel
you're it's you're more than half I've
been more than
uh happy for you to like you know what
you call it follow me on Twitch
subscribe on Twitch or you know on
patreon be a YouTube member be a YouTube
subscriber be a patreon member all that
kind of stuff it helps me out helps the
show and look guys you know
oh here it is just real quick you know
we have to do uh obviously we have to
finish off
with that rap recap shout out to my boy
Chris you
cause he'd be making those dope beats
Aaron Rodgers is out
that shout out
might have ended his career
he's at home in fear
all his peers
sending out that love
[Music]
even Jordan love
they had a fight
that [__] ain't right
girl gas man
now she laying on her back thank you for
watching my favorite Griffin
if you want to send a Beat Sammy and
Eric airgriffin.com if you're a budding
producer thank you for the comments
thank you for
being here as usual letting me like talk
off the top of my head very nuanced
conversations today
I'll say it again if you don't like it
please don't ever come to my channel
again
uh people don't like to like analyze
things and think things through and like
really look at the whole picture
thank you those people for being here
that like to do that everyone else you
know you're gonna do what you do but
thanks for watching Griffin with Griffin
and I will see you next week
[Music]